AND THAT’S MY OPEN.
LET ME KNOW WHAT YOU THINK ON
MY FACEBOOK AND TWITTER, #.
JUDGE JEANINE: .
JOINING ME NOW FROM THE FRONT
LINES THE FIGHT AGAINST THE
FRONT LINE ASSISTANT TO TRADE
AND MANUFACTURING PETER
NAVARRO.
PETER THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US TONIGHT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION
RIGHT NOW IS WHAT DO WE NEED,
AND HOW DO WE GET TO WHAT WE
NEED?
>> PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT, THAT IS THE
FRONTLINE FOR OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS IN ORDER TO TAKE THIS
VIRUS ON.
WHAT WE HAVE, THE FULL FORCE
AND POWER OF THE GOVERNMENT
AND PRIVATE ENTERPRISE, THE
FULL COOPERATION WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AS THEY
PRACTICE THEIR SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO BE DONE TO FIGHT THE
VIRUS IN THEIR WAY.
IT HAS REALLY BEEN GRATIFYING
TO ME TO IT WORK AT THE WHITE
HOUSE AND SEE HOW THIS
GOVERNMENT IS WORKING SO WELL
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO GET
THINGS DONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE YOU A
COUPLE EXAMPLES SOME OF THEM
WILL HIT PRETTY CLOSE TO
HOME.
THERE IS A COMMON GO THAT
MAKES ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
WE GOT A CALL LAST WEEK THEY
WANTED TO TAKE THEIR
PRODUCTION LINE ACROSS FOUR
STATES LIKE ARKANSAS, KENTUCKY
AND MAKE HAND SANITIZERS.
SO AS WE SPEAK THERE IS A
TRUCK MOVING TO NEW YORK CITY
WITH THEIR FIRST BATCH.
IT IS GOING TO BE HERE ON
TUESDAY.
AND DELIVERED DIRECTLY TO
HOSPITALS.
THERE’S A COMPANY CALLED ASO
WHICH, I JUST TALKED WITH
TODAY.
TODAY, WE WERE ABLE TO GET
HALF A MILLION GLOVES FROM ASO
AND PALMETTO FLORIDA TO THE
HOSPITALS IN NEW YORK.
IT’S GOING TO BE LANDING
TOMORROW.
AND SLOAN, ANOTHER COMPANY IN
TEXAS, AGAIN JUST TALKED TO
THEM TODAY, WE ARE GETTING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF JUMPSUITS
AND BOOTY COVERS THAT ARE
GOING TO GO BOTH SEATTLE AND
NEW YORK CITY.
THIS IS OVER AND ABOVE WHAT
FEMA IS DOING FROM THE
STOCKPILES.
AND THEN, HONEYWELL, WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE IN JUST A WEEK TO
GET THEM TO START STAFFING UP
A FACTORY IN RHODE ISLAND TO
INCREASE THE PRODUCTION OF
MASKS.
THERE IS A COALITION WITH THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF TRADE LED
BY A WOMAN CAN GLASS A VERY
DYNAMIC FIGURE.
SHE’S PUT TOGETHER FIGURES WHO
ARE USUALLY MAKING
UNDERGARMENTS AND TEACHERS,
THINGS LIKE THAT WITH HAYNES,
FRUIT OF THE LOOM, THEY’RE
GOING TO BE MAKING THREE PLY
MASKS.
WE SHOULD HAVE THAT UP IN
PRODUCTION AS WELL.
SO WE’VE GOT PLANES IN THE AIR
FROM FEMA, FEDEX, AND THE
MILITARY GOING ALL ACROSS THIS
GREAT COUNTRY.
SOMETIMES BRINGING STUFF FROM
AROUND THE WORLD SO THAT WE
GET WHAT WE NEED IN
REAL-TIME.
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THIS IS WHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS BRINGING
TOGETHER IN THIS CRISIS.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOU KNOW PETER,
WHAT YOU’RE TRYING BUT THE
THIRD POINT OF THE OPEN I JUST
MADE.
THAT’S COMMON GROUND.
PEOPLE WHO AREN’T NORMALLY IN
THE BUSINESS OF MAKING
SANITIZERS, THEY ARE IN THE
ALCOHOL BUSINESS, AND
UNDERSTAND YOU WERE AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS ABLE TO CUT
THROUGH WHAT WAS IT BOTH THE
FHA AS WELL AS TREASURY AND
OTHER DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE IT
GO SMOOTHER.
LOOK, THIS IS THE WHOLE
GOVERNMENT APPROACH, I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO DO IN GETTING
THIS TO ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT.
I KNOW, AND THE NEXT GUEST ON
MY SHOW, DOCTOR BEN CARSON IS
DOCTOR STEVE CORWIN WHO IS THE
HEAD OF THE PRESBYTERIAN THEY
ARE DESPERATE FOR MASKS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT SOME ARE NOW
GOING TO THEM.
HOW DO WE GET TO THE POINT
WHERE THIS NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN?
>> THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
THE PROBLEM WE FACE, AND IS I
TRY TO SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
PRESIDENT, HERE’S THE THING,
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN FOR
MEDICINES, MEDICAL SUPPLIES
AND MEDICAL EQUIPMENT, IS
SPREAD OUT ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
THAT WORKS FINE WHEN THERE IS
NO PROBLEM AND YOU DON’T NEED
THEM.
BUT CHECK THIS OUT, WE BUY
ABOUT $120 BILLION OF
MEDICINES EVERY YEAR FROM THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
ABOUT 95% OF THEM COME IN FOR
ABOUT 20 COUNTRIES.
GUESS WHAT JUDGE, TEN OF THOSE
COUNTRIES HAVE ALREADY IMPOSED
SOME SORT OF EXPORT
RESTRICTIONS ON THINGS THAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED.
IT’S A SITUATION WHERE WE
FOUND OURSELVES IN MANY OF OUR
SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY WERE WE
HAVE OFFSHORE OUR JOBS,
MACHINE TOOLS, ELECTRONICS,
STEEL, WHATEVER IT IS, THAT
COST US JOBS.
IN THIS CASE ACOSTA’S LIVES.
SO ONE OF THE LESSONS I HOPE I
LEARNED IS AFTER THIS IS OVER
SO WE CAN BRING IT TO AMERICA,
MAKE THE MEDICINES, MAKE THEM
FACEMASKS HERE.
>> .
JUDGE JEANINE: WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP AMERICA FIRST, MADE IN
AMERICA THAT’S PERFECT SENSE
IT’S TIME TO TELL THE REST OF
THE WORLD WE ARE NOT GOING TO
RELY ON THEM ANYMORE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR MEDICATION.
AND YOU KNOW FOR ME, NUCLEAR
MEDICINE IS MAKING ME CRAZY AS
WELL.
PETER NAVARRO, THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU’RE DOING.
I WANT TO KNOW HOW YOU’RE ABLE
TO DO THIS 24-7 AND YOU ALL
STILL IN GREAT.
>> I AM JUST SO PROUD OF THIS
PRESIDENTS IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND THE PEOPLE WORKING IN
GOVERNMENT AND BUSINESS RIGHT
NOW.
AND THE PEOPLE OF AMERICA WHO
ARE COOPERATING WITH WHAT THEY
NEED IN TERMS OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
I SALUTE YOU AND LET’S STAY ON
IT HERE.